alors comment ne pas perdre trop
d'argent pour pouvoir se verser un
salaire après avoir payé toutes ces
charges c'est la difficile équation à
laquelle tente de répondre chaque jour
commerçants et artisans le pouvoir
d'achat est la principale préoccupation
des français les candidats à la
présidentielle ont ils bien compris
c'est l'objet de notre face à face
est avec nous pour en parler ce soir
vincent chauvet maire modem d'hôtes un
bon soir vincent chauvet merci d'être
avec nous à vos côtés guillaume roux
bokashi porte parole de fabien roussel
candidat du parti communiste donc à la
présidentielle merci à vous d'être là
également on est les oubliés nous dit
sébastien ayats tout comment tout
augmente prix de l'énergie prix des
matières premières et notre boulanger
qui réclament de juste pouvoir vivre de
son travail en étant payés au juste prix
il a raison comme dirait certaine c'est
une colère scène guillaume robot gâchis
bien sûr vous êtes une personne parce
que la france qui est une grande
puissance mondiale est en train de
devenir un pays de bas salaires et ça ne
peut pas continuer comme ça c'est un
problème pour les gens qui vit avec ses
bas salaires c'est un problème pour
l'économie générale du pays puis c'est
un problème de justice sociale de ce
point de vue oui c'est un problème et
nous nous demandons une augmentation
forte de la rémunération et notamment du
chimique avec une augmentation qui
l'amènerait à 1500 euros net parce que
il faut pouvoir vivre dignement de son
travail
vincent chauvet même constat comment
répondre à la priorité de sébastien qui
est celle évidemment de nombreux
français c'est-à-dire faire en sorte que
les prix déjà de n'augmenter plus
bon effectivement on voit très bien chez
ce boulanger
le constat est très clair il est partagé
pas partout en france
qu' il ya une pression sur les matières
premières il ya une pression sur les
salariés il faut aussi payer dans un
contexte de pénurie sur le marché de
travail de baisse du chômage il faut le
dire eh bien il faut payer de plus en
plus ses salariés pour qu'il reste et
pour avoir des bons salariés motivés et
on voit pour ce petit patron que
finalement le dernier as payé quand il a
payé ses empreintes ses charges ses
salariés ses matières premières ses
fournisseurs c'est lui et donc
effectivement là il ya un souci quand
est il a été très bien montré un
reportage on a à la fois une hausse
importante des prix de l'énergie et puis
pour les salariés mais aussi pour les
commerçants une hausse importante des
prix de l'immobilier donc on peut agir
sur plusieurs leviers lé prix l'énergie
les prix de l'immobilier on peut agir
sur la fiscalité mais typiquement pour
ce petit boulanger une hausse du smic
n'aurait strictement aucun effet et ça
ne devrait pas à regagner du chiffre
d'affaires on va regagner des clients et
des marges alors je me repose oui
allez-y elle hésite entre un petit mot
d'être un petit mot là j'ai parlé du
public parce que c'est un événement pris
dans la main du pouvoir public après on
a fléchi nous voulons aller vers une
augmentation générale des salaires et la
pousser dans son stade et l'état des
instruments s'il souhaite le faire mais
ne disons pas que se nourrir de bonnes
façons ça n'a aucun rapport avec avec le
pouvoir d'achat c'est pas vrai comment
dire de les boulangers de qualité il
offre des produits que n'offrent pas
toujours les supermarchés si on veut
avoir du bon pain et donc c'est pas vrai
que de considérer que d'augmenter le
niveau des salaires dans la population
générale nom n'est pas de soutenir le
nombre de clients qui existent auprès de
plongée je crois pas qu'on puisse se
poser des choses comme ça en tout cas je
voulais vous proposer une première
réaction de téléspectateurs à la
question de savoir si le pouvoir d'achat
et bien c'est la priorité numéro un des
français alex j ai bien vu le prix de
l'essence et l'électricité difficile
d'avoir d'autres priorités aujourd'hui
guillaume roux beau gâchis finalement
c'est une chance ou un piège pour
emmanuel macron cette priorité 1 du
pouvoir d'achat alors qu'on sait que son
bilan sécuritaire est souvent critiquée
en gros finalement est-ce que ça peut
l'aider manuel maquereau ou au contraire
lui desservir eu égard à son bilan sur
cette question écoutez évidemment si on
regarde les choses vu de loin on
pourrait penser que ça peut l'aider et
il s'appuie sur des chiffres de
dévolution d'en moyenne du pouvoir
d'achat et donc quand le fc eu par
exemple indique que le pouvoir d'achat
en moyenne des français a beaucoup
augmenté mais quand on regarde le sco
dit lui même au fc eu par exemple pour
le début du quinquennat qu'est ce qu'il
dit il dit que un quart de
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat gagné
par l'ensemble des français est allé aux
5 % des ménages les plus aisés donc non
elle m'apprend n'a pas un bon bilan
quand on regarde vraiment ce qu'est
l'évolution du pouvoir d'achat de
l'ensemble des français et il a mené une
politique de président des riches
vincent chauvet parce que c'est vrai que
il lie il ya une vraie polémique un sûre
en tout cas une confusion l'insee 1
tiens on va voir d'ailleurs les chiffres
par exemple fait polémique car parce que
la majorité comme unique allègrement sur
les chiffres de l'insee présente
emmanuel macron comme le président du
pouvoir d'achat regardez d'ailleurs ce
tweet avant nous faire réagir du député
la reine gilles legendre
en 2021 près de 4 millions de nos
concitoyens ont bénéficié de la prime
acron versée par les entreprises s'en
charger sans impôt sur la base du
volontariat les salariés ont touché en
moyenne 5 106 euros
le président du pouvoir d'achat c'est
emmanuel macron voilà alors ça c'est ce
que nous dit le député la reine et
soutenu un petit peu par les chiffres de
l'insee sauf que le pouvoir d'achat
c'est un peu comme la météo houaria la
température en chiffre égal ressenti sur
le terrain ça vous en avez quand même
conscience parce que boulanger je pense
qu'il n'est pas vraiment d'accord avec
jean le genre noir
oui oui absolument il y a le les
chiffres de l'insee et puis le le
ressenti notamment parce qu'il ya aussi
une différence entre le pouvoir d'achat
finalement le le pouvoir d'achat
arbitrable quand on a un certain nombre
de dépenses contraintes et les prix de
l'énergie sont des dépenses contraintes
le plein pour aller travailler c'est une
dépense contrainte et qu'on voit plus
facilement les chiffres lumineux sur la
station service en bas de chez soi que
des augmentations de 1 ou 2 % de
dépenses arbitrable en fin de mois ce
que dit gilles legendre est très vrai et
nous au modem on veut aussi poussé ce
vrai sujet de pouvoir d'achat qui est un
vrai sujet bien plus important je pense
dans la tête des français et pour le
pays que de pseudo polémique sur
l'immigration ou la sécurité mais sur le
pouvoir d'achat effectivement ce qui a
été fait est ce que nous souhaiterions
pérenniser c'est la prime macro pourquoi
parce que c'est extrêmement simple et
aussi parce que ce n'est pas de la
démagogie c'est pas des promesses en
l'air c'est pas des promesses de gascon
c'est une négociation entre patrons et
salariés quand une entreprise fait des
bénéfices et bien en fin d'année peut
distribuer un deux voire trois smic et
de manière extrêmement simple soit en
direct soit sur des plans des parades
des parts salariales le général de
gaulle ne disait pas autre amant et donc
avec emmanuel macron à la suite
d'ailleurs de la crise des jeunes qui
aussi partie sur le pouvoir d'achat il
faut s'en souvenir et bien cette prime
acron est un trait succès est là prêt a
permis un meilleur partage de des
richesses et notamment un meilleur
partage des marges et des bénéfices des
entreprises au cours des dernières
années ça a été créé un peu comme ça et
finalement c'est très simple ça marche
bien et nous on propose sur le
quinquennat prochain si la majorité
présentielle président de la république
est réélu de le pérenniser parce qu'il
faut à la fois à faire confiance aux
entreprises aux salariés et aux
négociations salariales mais aussi à des
sportifs simple parce que aujourd'hui
l'actionnariat salarié la participation
ça peut être compliqué la prime mâcon
c'est simple et ça marche guillaume roux
beau gâchis la prime à coron ça marchera
pas que ça on va voir pendant que vous
vous exprimez les autres mesures macro
notamment sur l'énergie le chèque de 100
euros sur l'énergie la taxe d'habitation
il ya eu quelques mesures que vente
allègrement évidemment la majorité
qu'est ce que vous répondez
c'est qu'un début c'est alors un début
pas mal
non non mais j'imagine qu'il devrait
mettre pendant les gains de pouvoir
d'achat ils ne devraient que la
suppression de l'impôt sur la fortune
toutes les mesures énorme qui ont privé
l'état de monsieur 2 argent de manière
considérable pour faire des cadeaux aux
plus riches alors ceux du gain de
pouvoir d'achat très bien mais pour les
très très riches ça ça compte beaucoup
plus que les petites pièces est envoyé
et c'est pas sa demande nous ne
demandons pas la charité des primes des
petites des petites miettes comme ça on
demande une augmentation des salaires de
pouvoir vivre dignement de son travail
et si on parle de la fonction publique
puisque on a parlé du secteur privé
c'est vrai quand même rappeler qu'avec
l'inflation qui arrive le gel du point
d'indicé qui existe depuis bientôt 15
ans il est insupportable
écoutez moi je vous parlais que vers
l'avant d'exemple d'enseignants je suis
enseignant on a une prime blanc coeur de
35 euros par mois 35 euros par mois ça
suffit mais j'ai plus envie d'avoir une
prime blanca ou 35 euros par an ça
suffit donc non il faut être très clair
sur la question des salariés du privé il
ya besoin d'augmenter les salaires
regardez ce qui se passe en allemagne on
parle d'augmenter le smic de 20% il faut
augmenter le smic qui font augmenter le
smic a augmenté l'ensemble des salaires
il faut garantir des pensions qu'ils ne
soient pas au-dessous de 1200 euros
grâce notamment notre député andré
chassaigne il ya eu des mesures
intéressant pour des prises en direction
des retraites agricoles il faut
continuer il faut aller plus loin mais
là ne parlons pas de cette
généralisation de ce système de primes
de deux petites pièces de charité c'est
pas ça le sujet le sujet c'est est ce
que dans notre pays on peut vivre
dignement de son travail vincent chauvet
je vais vous montrer un sondage ifop
largue qui montrent effectivement les
trois catégories qui ont le moins
bénéficié des mesures appliquées durant
ce quinquennat vous le voyez en bas de
non c'est pas ce chiffre mais en bas de
tableau les classes moyennes on va le
voir peut-être les habitants des
communes rurales et les retraités le
président est quand même passé à côté
depuis cinq ans c'est ça rejoint ce que
vient de nous dire guillaume roux beau
gâchis enfin c'est vrai que voilà 35 ans
pouvoir de 35 euros pouvoir d'achat pour
les profs sais c'est pas c'est pas
beaucoup quand même il faut changer tout
le système
oui alors d'une part effectivement il y
avait une anomalie dans notre système
social c'est que le niveau de vie moyen
des retraités était supérieur à celui
des actifs donc j'ai pas qu'il faille
baisser le niveau de vie des retraités
mais il ya eu une politique pendant ce
quinquennat effectivement de redonner du
pouvoir d'achat aux actifs et ça a
marché après je pense que tous les
candidats sont d'accord notamment une
période de croissance et de retour de la
hausse des prix de l'énergie l'inflation
sous jacente qu'il faille augmenter les
salaires bon ça c'est évident en
revanche les là où les programmes vont
se comparer c'est sur comment nous on
pense qu'augmenter le smic c'est une
promesse qui coûte pas grand chose à
l'état qui repose sur les patrons dans
des entreprises qui dans certains
secteurs ont des marges qui sont tendues
avec un et serait d'écrasement des
salaires et des bas salaires au niveau
du smic avec des gens qui parfois ont
attendu dix ou quinze ans pour sortir du
smic et au jury qui pourraient se
retrouver si cette mesure est expliqué
et appliqué de nouveau au niveau du
salaire minimum c'est pas forcément
souhaitable et comme je le dis il y à
des mesures qui sont pas du tout de
l'aumône et avoir alors que quand on est
à fonctionner on s'en rend peut être pas
compte mais quand on travaille dans le
privé d'avoir une prime défiscaliser de
1 ou 2 mois de salaire à la fin de
l'année quand l'entreprise a bien bossé
et que collectivement à dégager de la
marge ça compte et sur le court no 10
des fonctionnaires je pense qu'il faut
qu'il y ait en effet en effet une
réflexion ça fait trop longtemps que le
laisse le point d'indicé est gelé on va
pas dire que les salaires des
fonctionnaires seront gelés puisque il
ya une progression mécanique année après
année donc ne faisons pas croire que les
les fonctionnaires non plus n'est n'est
pas eu des revalorisations effectivement
le point lundi et est quand même gelé et
le niveau de vie des fonctionnaires a
évolué moins vite que l'inflation avec
pour certaines catégories une perte de
pouvoir d'achat on voit notamment à des
catégories de fonctionnaires qui sont
plus du tout attractif ou moins
attractifs les profs il ya eu un débat
et anne hidalgo a raison je pense de
dire qu'il faille augmenter le salaire
des profs mais nous aussi dans la
fonction publique territoriale dans les
mairies dans les communes quand on veut
embaucher du personnel et que dans le
privé on gagne 20 ou 30% plus cher ça
devient compliqué et donc
ça coûte ça va coûter aux finances
publiques c'est une réflexion globale
qu'il faut avoir mais il n'est pas en
tout cas quand je reçois les syndicats
sur ces revendications il n'est pas
inconcevable de le faire je note
néanmoins on vient de passer le parti
communiste serait pas très content mais
on vient passer de nouveau de retour aux
35 heures ont travaillé trente deux
heures et demie dans un certain nombre
de communes on est passé de nouveaux 35
heures dans la fonction publique d'état
on a fait passer un nouveau régime
indemnitaire donc il ya eu même sur la
mort avec un gel douche un 10e gain de
pouvoir d'achat en tout cas c'est l'une
des mesures phares du de fabien roussel
1 pour ce pouvoir d'achat l'augmentation
du smic 1 voyez ces candidats de gauche
fabien roussel a va jusqu'à augmenter le
smic à 1800 euros
guy roux beau gâchis ça coûterait 53
milliards tout de même aux entreprises
ans selon l'observatoire est ce que
c'est la question j'imagine qu'on vous
pose souvent mais ce que vous avez pas
peur parti communiste de freiner la
compétitivité tout de même des
entreprises
il ya deux choses d'abord si on veut
toujours aller plus bas dans la
rémunération des gens on peut rappeler
peut-être le niveau du smic en romani et
500 euros aussi l'idée c'est toujours
attention si vous augmentez les salaires
tout le monde va partir en roumanie mais
il va falloir payer colle les gens
convient donc ils ne partent pas en
roumanie c'est un argument qui va nous
amener jusqu'à la misère non je ne pense
pas qu'il faille trop tirer sept corps
de la par ailleurs pour il faut aussi
affronter plusieurs questions et à la
question des charges et notamment des
charges liées aux frais bancaires aux
frais d'assurance aux frais
d'électricité et dont nous avons une
politique ambitieuse en la matière nous
pensons qu'il faut développer un pôle
public de l'assurance un pôle public
bancaire en nationalisant parce que
c'est ça qui on revient faire la société
générale en nationalisant les banques de
la bnp en nationalisant axa par exemple
dont il faut baisser ces charges la
importantes qui sont là bas oui la
louche et évidemment vous aimez
privatiser je comprends facile d'aller
des grands regard on les privatiser à
peu près tous comprend bien maintenant
on peut avoir une ambition pour notre
pays et je pense est important donc
cette question là il ya aussi évidemment
l'effet des mesures à prendre en matière
d'électricité nous nous pensons qu
effectivement il faut reprendre la main
sur le contrôle du prix d'électricité et
avoir une baisse significative en la
matière une baisse significative
également du côté de l'essence parce que
on sait très bien que sont les taxes qui
représentent l'essentiel du coût payé à
la pompe quand on éteint quand on va
chercher de l'essence donc de ce côté là
évidemment il ya aussi la mise en place
d'une taxe flottante nous disons qu'il
faut mettre ça en place rapidement donc
oui je suis on est bien conscient que
pour les entreprises c'est pas facile de
s'en sortir mais justement nous pensons
et nous avons des propositions en la
matière merci en tout cas à tous les
deux vincent chauvet guillaume robot
caché d'avoir accepté ce face à face et
c'est la fin de cette émission